Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Musica)
Tuttavia, ne rimase un piccolo stormo.
E questi decisero di andare
alla ricerca della resilienza,
volando ora in testa ora in coda,
come una cosa sola.
"Alla ricerca di Simurg"
è la storia possibile di un'utopia,
quella che, dopo un viaggio
per mare o per terra,
ci vede tutti uccelli migranti,
alla ricerca delle risposte
a un bisogno di senso.
E lo trova in un canto corale.
Noi siamo il Coro Voci Dal Mondo,
una comunità aperta all'incontro
con tutte le diversità.
Siamo cocai veneziani,
aquile della Costa d'Avorio,
usignoli siciliani, condor,
colibrì, cormorani.
Il nostro canto è un garrito calabrese,
un cinguettio rumeno,
pigoliamo in Pidgin English
e trilliamo in tedesco e ungherese.
I cantanti migranti
della rotta mediterranea
oggi volgono lo sguardo ai fratelli
e alle sorelle dalla rotta balcanica.
Qualcuno di loro con 50 gradi all'ombra,
nei campi di container della Grecia,
qualcuno di loro più avanti, nell'orrore,
magari dopo un inverno in Bosnia,
col fango e la neve che bruciano i piedi,
non tanto diversamente
dal deserto della Libia.
Vi invitiamo, dunque,
ad alzarvi in volo con noi,
forse solo per il tempo di un concerto,
forse per le prossime date
assieme al Coro Voci dal Mondo
e a tanti altri che si
uniranno al nostro canto.
Se lo vorrete, potrete portarci
anche uno strumento musicale.
Stiamo montando una carovana
per andare incontro a quelle persone,
ai campi dove restano bloccate,
alle comunità locali che attraversano,
per ritrovare assieme
un'umanità dimenticata,
per scambiarci le parole e le canzoni.
Uno strumento e, per chi lo vorrà,
anche un messaggio, un recapito,
per una relazione
di reciprocità e di conoscenza.
Vieni con noi,
non importa chi vola in testa
e chi vola in coda,
formiamo tutti una cosa sola.
(Applausi)